[Music]
Japan a country that brags about two
things the first is there used underwear
vending machines which yes you really
can find on the street and the second is
their integration rate which is by far
the lowest in the developed world for
comparison in the United States the
immigrant population is about 14% Canada
and New Zealand have 20 and 25%
respectively and then this Japan with an
immigration population of less than 2%
so what's the reason for this well quite
simply it's they're very restrictive
immigration system
this makes Japan something of a dream
countries of politicians like Donald
Trump all marine lepen if there is one
word that could define the current
political debate that word would be
immigration in Europe countries are
arguing about what to do with refugees
and it seems the politicians across the
board seem to think that immigration is
the problem that needs to be stopped
immigrations fallen under this
government and we've cut net migration
by 1/3 anyone who illegally crosses the
border will be detained until they are
removed out of our country and back to
the country from which they came since I
took office we've deployed more border
agents and technology to our southern
border than ever before so then Japan is
a perfect example of what a country
would look like without really many
immigrants at all and so now you might
be wondering what exactly does that mean
for Japan's economy
do they really save money because they
don't have to spend on social policies
for immigrants further the Japanese
workers enjoy a higher standard of life
because they don't have to compete for
jobs with foreign workers and on this
episode of visuals politic we aren't
going to be answering those questions
but before we get into all of that we
need to have a close look at Japan's
immigration law
one country one culture one brain this
statement was said by the man who was
the Prime Minister of Japan in the
mid-1980s
this man was Yasuhiro Nakasone a the
statement clearly summarizes the
immigration policy of Japan basically
there are just two ways to get into the
Land of the Rising Sun one is with a
work contract and the other is with a
tourist visa if a company wants to hire
you from overseas you will need a work
visa and the only possible way that you
can get that visa is you have a
university degree or have some specific
skills that are practically impossible
to find in the Japanese labor market so
if you are just a construction worker
you are never going to get a work permit
for Japan that is unless you use this
other program in Kaplan
Kamala Pagnotta formally Japan didn't
have a lot to accept workers from
Moderation countries like Vietnam or
Philippines they created the so-called
technical and internal training program
this in summary is sort of like being an
intern in Japan except you get about
half the salaries that a Japanese intern
would get not only that but with this
technical internal training program
your boss is even allowed to hold on to
your passport and access your bank
account
more worryingly than that since they
started this program thousands of Asian
immigrants have simply disappeared
oh I forgot to show power source when
the UN representative a spoke with me
she said that my attitude was bad and
that if I continue to have this heavy
view if my actions continue her friend
will hire a hitman to kill me crash I
shall so well what if you enter with a
tourist visa well in that case you can
stand the country for a year and a half
as long as you can prove that you are
studying Japanese once that initial time
is passed you need to get hired by a
company this can lead to you getting a
work visa but do watch out here because
unlike in the United States or certain
European countries this work visa
stipulates what your profession is so
for example if you get that work visa
saying that you are a chef then you can
only work in a restaurant if you break
this rule and do some sort of other
works and the government will not renew
your visa there is only one really
effective way for a foreigner if you
make a living in Japan
Lumos tequila given a was like the
easiest thing bleep here is marrying a
Japanese person now I hope you
understand why in a country with over
127 million inhabitants only 2 million
of them immigrants but what consequences
does this have on the daily lives of
Japanese citizens
[Music]
parfaits is Japanese fashion Japan is
the oldest country in the world not
because of their long history but
because of the actual physical age of
their population in fact destination say
this in the next 90 years they're going
to lose about 44 million people from
their population which is about the
entire population of Canada now this
wouldn't be a problem if it wasn't for
the Social Security system as you
probably know the point as you know the
pension system in most countries in the
world works in the following way the
people who are working today are the
ones who are paying the pensions of the
people who are retired today as the
workforce gets smaller and smaller year
after year the number of people paying
those pensions is getting smaller
further on the other side of things more
and more people are retiring if you are
drawing more and more social security
and this leads to problems like this
social security contributions cover only
60 percent of these benefits the
remaining 40 trillion yen comes from
taxes or more precisely public deficits
[Music]
by the way the music you're hearing in
this video is from the Spanish bands
Matt Kalina if you like it and want to
check out more of their stuff and do you
look in the description box
[Music]
and this is why and pay attention to
this part Japan has the highest public
debt of any country in the world their
current debt level is more than double
their GDP and their fiscal deficit the
difference between their income and
their spending is higher than the one in
the United States in other words if
Angela Merkel were to go to Japan she'd
probably get very very angry so now you
might be wondering well what does all of
this have to do with immigration well
the answer is a lot you see we've all
heard about how expensive it is to
integrate immigrants you have to pay for
social programs integration courses etc
etc but no one really talks about how
much a native citizen cost for example
an American born citizen costs the
government 150 thousand dollars by the
time they are age 16 and this is only
for education and health care depending
on the state that that person lives in
you might have to add in other expenses
but the government sees all of this as
an investment because when that person
starts paying taxes they're going to get
that money back on the other hand let's
take an example of a Vietnamese
immigrants to Japan he comes to the
country when he is old enough to start
work his education and health care was
already paid for by the Vietnamese
and in an average of two years as
Anthony's immigrant is going to find a
job now of course that job might be a
low page one and my page is the little
tack that the Japanese government didn't
have to invest any money into it so in
other words immigrants are free cash for
the government since Japan has so few
immigrants they are losing out on this
easy influx of cash this is why in the
middle of the fiscal crisis in 2015 the
japanese prime minister shinzo are they
made the following announced
Japan and their pressure to accept more
immigrants as workforce strength but
despite what it looks like this is not
just hands biggest problem Japan has
seen the last 20 years go by with no
economic growth this is what experts
have called the lost decades and it has
a lot to do with immigration as well
concrete that is stopped innovating we
all imagine Japan as a country of
technology and innovation the country
where companies like Nintendo Sony
Toshiba where they were all born
something less the reality is these
companies are really old Nintendo was
founded in 1889 and Toyota was created
in 1937 actually can anybody name any
Japanese companies that were created in
the 21st century you probably couldn't
but on the other hand you could probably
name five to ten American companies that
were formed during the same period
immigrant Ponder's service 52% of all
new Silicon Valley companies between
1995 and 2005 the entrepreneurial rate
among immigrant populations is 2 to 3
times higher than native and this is a
trend that you find in every country for
instance one of the founders of Google
Sergey Brin was born in Moscow further
the co-founder of whatsapp was born in
Ukraine this isn't just about Silicon
Valley startup just take a walk around
your neighborhood and you'll see
hundreds of Chinese stores Mexican
restaurants and all of the kinds of
small businesses created by immigrants
and it does make complete sense that
immigrants will have an entrepreneurial
spirit at the end of the day those who
leave their home country are risk takers
not only that but immigrants bring
wisdoms their culture to a new country
which helps them in thinking outside of
the box let's take a look as another
example Charles Belmont was a German
immigrants to New York City in the 19th
century soon he realized that the
workers in the city needed some sort of
food that could be cooked and sold on
the street that's when he decided to
import sausages from his home country
and that's when the hot dog was born
today this meal feeds millions of people
from all around the planet and this this
is just one example there are thousands
upon thousands more in short when
cultures mix new ideas and methodologies
are created this is what business people
call innovation and this this is the
special source that makes companies and
countries
so well what's going on in Japan
unsurprisingly Japan has the lowest
entrepreneurial rate in the developed
world just 7% of the population decides
to start a business by comparison in
countries like Canada and New Zealand
that percentage is about 10% the
Japanese dream isn't to start your own
business it's to get hired by one that
already exists you know those big
companies that we previously mentioned
like Sony and Toshiba companies that
have the same corporate and work
structure that they had in the 1980s
traditional Japanese electronic power
houses such as sharp and Sony having
Kurt huge losses and shed thousands of
jobs
welcome phasers Apple and Samsung have
continued to increase their market share
lately like football what Americans call
soccer why keep up with the World Cup or
the USA championship 20 years ago there
were at least two Japanese companies
sponsoring these events in 2016 the
European Cup had no Japanese sponsors
and no matter where you look Japanese
companies are struggling to compete with
European American and even Chinese
companies and the reason is not a lack
of money it's a lack of innovation and
this explains why Japan's economy has
been so frozen over the last decade
and the course this is having a major
impact on the lives of Japan citizens in
order to keep productivity up Japanese
workers have the longest working hours
and the shortest holidays of any
developed nation meanwhile they still
have the same salaries that the parents
so that is our opinion here at visual
politic and now we would love to know
yours do you think Japan should open its
doors to immigrants or do you think
other countries should follow Japan's
example and close their doors to
immigrants use the comment section below
to let us know also if you enjoyed this
video please do give us a thumbs up
below and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos every Monday and
Thursday and I'll see you next time
[Music]
and then our lanai